when you are on the lesson page and  reading  this is a very important part of  certainly of my learning on link i  listen a lot more than i read i listen a  lot because i can do it whenever i want  in the car washing dishes and so forth  but then i want to get back to the  lesson page where i'm mining so to speak  this text for more hints about the  language noticing things uh seeing these  yellow links that i've created before  don't forget that you can adjust the  font on your lesson page you can also  decide whether you want to review the in  the settings you can either review your  words after every page or not do that  you can also set  the settings so that when you move to  another page all the words you didn't  say won't automatically be turned to  white so  be familiar with all the settings and  make sure you derive the maximum benefit  from working with your lesson page  that's a big part of your learning